we are live welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 29 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the rental table and the Lord's Day
I'm very excited about our special guest
so we're gonna get right on today I want
to introduce the Lord who I met in the
flesh and I very first eat together in
2015
I've watched this launch journey and not
only becoming one of the top content
creator also for his amazing business
savvy and the campus treats this Lord is
always calm and collected I'll provide
an extremely informative and insightful
content yet is never afraid to check
fanboys and their feelings of a false
statement introducing be changes in
charge the host of the Brooklyn skill
tree podcast and the creator of the
number one raw and uncut podcast and
he's getting in streets mister weapon
will himself not bad
Lord VG what's going on everybody
glad to be on appreciate the invite
pleasure to have you pleasure to have
you do how you doing today I'm good and
of course we have the usual suspects at
the round table
my co-host with the Como's a brother
from another mother and the house of the
young wolf my bed Lord addict are we
doing sir just waiting for this destiny
to you
absolutely absolutely and unfortunately
we don't have our most technical Gaming
Lord this Lord has fallen down we'll be
back now feeling well under the weather
we better head back
but of course access gate oh the Lord
who is a man of his conviction
nothing less than the premium experience
Oh beloved Lord King how are we doing
sir we're doing fantastic
Oh everybody got in that power yo the
numbers came in for the Floyd cut of the
Kroger numbers blue evilly okay away
point six million and the numbers keep
growing he's walking away for his self
he get this for his self 150 you
understand like before the numbers was
coming they estimated the same thing as
Pacquiao two points two point six
million then he would have walked away
with a good 70 you know even even after
his cut with Dana no no no now after his
cut with Dana in the UFC your boy walk
away with 150 we're not even talking
about Floyd numbers we know Floyd
numbers is four hundred and better he
might crack half a billy yeah that's
crazy what are you doing boy fight the
tremendous yes right everybody sitting
at the decafs is telling you oh nobody
want to see it nobody cared about it the
world stopped and took a moment and
looked at the two greatest of their
sports or the two most entertaining of
this but this is what happened when you
have the two most entertaining loves the
same you know combat sport world come
together any mesh the world town stands
up to take notice and they voted with
your wallet it was getting our boxing
numbers in of course iron Lords the
hunter who helped build the ILP movement
from the very beginning
mr. Haiti Ho himself the plethora of
leaks or destiny tune and just excited
for it come out absolutely Davian in the
building what was one of the original
brick builders
of course look I didn't hear spending
that gaming realness on the ILP not
telling you what you wanted here which
you need it
so before we get into what the Lords are
playing I want to first start off with
Lord BG's video game system history what
inspired the creation of the world's
number one gaming podcast that weapon
will and of course one of my favorites
the Brooklyn skill tree so uh Robby G
tell me about like gaming in the
beginning for you and I know you you're
multi-platform guys but like what was
the first system or console or PC sorry
one second was over here what give me
one minute
no worries we get back to so while we
wait knowing our Lord BG for a second I
gotta say this though I gotta say this
o0y oh it's kinda like kismet to be
honest with you
because destiny is coming out this
weekend do you know that feeling you
know I mean no disrespect to lava lava
play because I know mine is right now I
want a warlock out so bad right now I'll
be honest with ya detox myself from
destiny one to her a few months now
right not so good right back to you the
question is like I said we know that um
as far as you're a multi-platform guy
and also a PC guy so I want to start off
first with like your video game history
and then we can get in till I kind of
what inspired the number one podcast in
these streets that weapon will and of
course the Brooklyn skill tree so what
was like the first system or maybe PC
that you had as far as a gachi in the
game Nintendo Super Nintendo yeah
that's an SAE yes so those one of those
early days talk to me
parents my parents bought me that when I
was like five I think and they
definitely got me you know for Super
Mario game donkey the donkey kong what
else they got me with that I know it was
in my first two games yes so let's talk
IV here I'm surprised buddies oh yeah
man I listen I've had every Nintendo
console it's just it's just like the
only ones I didn't like I like people
think like there's just this
long-wearing hate for Nintendo and I
know the first console of Nintendo I
didn't like that they made was the UM
was the Wii because it was such a
departure from what they know what we
used to they're makin so absolutely yeah
i loved it i love nintendo before that
cool they do in super casual and push
you to the left so did after the super
nes like what did you transition to like
after that like far as a generation so
what happened and i guess might actually
like made me the way I am now so I
actually wanted a n64 after that right
but for some reason you know my parents
got me a PlayStation instead and my
cousin got an n64 and I was tight and I
was like I want this PlayStation is
[Laughter]
remember on what will you was like I
just sometimes I just see here think
what would have happen if I got a n64 it
would have been comfort it would have
probably wasn't completely left we've
been you know real different but yeah
they got me the police station I didn't
wanted at first I was mad cuz I you know
you had I had two previous Nintendo
consoles so obviously you want the next
one and I got the PlayStation I got the
PlayStation first instead and then I got
an n64 I enjoyed both but you know the
after that the PlayStation became
console absolutely I guess one was crazy
any-any standing on titles for you that
used to to rock a lot for ps1
of course crash spyro see that crash
logo looking very fire yes
Syphon Filter did you play bobo play
what Tobal the fighting game when the
first came out it was like the first 60
frames per second fighting game and it
kind of look like the from the guy who
made the Dragon Ball Z characters that
was probably my best like a collabo game
was like square and yeah yeah I don't
remember it on that I played played
tumba fighting force because it was a
Soul Reaver yeah nice nice alright so
that you went from PlayStation or last
so then when did I know you also a
hardcore PC guy now when did that
transition kind of happened as well as
another curious about that I had always
like when I was younger like playing a
little bit I used to play like a lot of
age of the Empire's especially all on
the the original one and a few other PC
games I don't know if you ever remember
this game soldier of fortune yeah I was
actually one of my favorite like you
know first person shooters back in the
day this is a lewin like my parents
wouldn't get me that many games so I you
know I only could select a few also a
Medal of Honor
allied assault I played that on PC I was
younger
and then when I got a little bit you
know when I was able to build my own rig
that was like you know when I got back
to like you know I guess hardcore PC
gaming that was like 2010 mm-hmm yeah
that's when I really started to buy it
you know all the multiplex on PC and
everything nice nice that's when you
became part of that master race
cool so did not want to transition now
as far but he doesn't do the waiting
[ __ ] I got to respect that yeah you
gotta respect that when did that start
how did that whole thing come to be
because you guys are killing it out here
so whatever button you have
yeah so we've been going like two and a
half years now maybe two years yeah and
yeah it all started because I'm like you
know there's a lot of podcasts of people
that agree with each other and like each
other a lot
let me put together a podcast where we
don't necessarily like each other and we
don't agree which you know as people
seen that works out sometimes and a lot
of times it don't but you know with all
the you know the fighting it's just a
part is just a part of it like you know
cuz you know typically the people have
people in a podcast that they all agree
on really like yeah yeah generally like
or have respect for you know like I'm
the host and like I you know there's
like this it just one person in there at
least two people maybe that I actually
don't like I think weapon wails might be
the only podcast on all respect my
question to you is are like because of
that is such a unique concept
I really respect but because it I like
how the are you able to manage all the
different personalities because clearly
we've seed you know with some members
but heizo guys always seem to get it
back together and always the chemistry
still then it's a great show so like how
do you how's that like the whole
managing of that go for you I mean
honestly uh I would say half the time I
might say something after sama I don't
say anything at all I just I just let
people fight it out and I just watch
let's play the background yeah I just I
just watched because in it most of the
time it works itself out amazingly like
like you like with some of the
situations you'd be like yo there's no
way they coming back from this way too
far left they would let it and it's
somehow just it gets brought back so you
know it works I'm glad he's still doing
it and again you guys are killing it
with that with appreciate that and the
last question I have for you Memphis
tonight was on the Brooklyn squeal skill
tree which is something I've seen you
know that you kind of do on the side
afterwards so how did that start and you
know tell me about the whole concept
mind I wanted to do like you know an
in-person podcast and I know you know
Ricky and red they both live live in my
area Oh
close enough of my face yeah you know
Brooklyn of course I saw it and it was
just some people I was like already cool
with anyway like you know like some
people actually chill within the rail so
I hit them up on Leigh Ellis let's do it
on camera podcast and I thought it was a
good good idea it worked out we don't
get to do it as often because you know
it's a lot easier to do a podcast you
don't gotta win you don't gotta go
nowhere you just meet up on Google
Hangouts but yeah we try to meet up at
least like maybe once a month once every
two months and do it and yeah it's cool
definitely definitely enjoyed Brooklyn
skills country a lot as well and now I
remember we if you remember we kicked it
a little bit where you back at your
first teach me in 2015 we ran up to your
trade if you remember you know every
every black person at e3 was doing the
head nod and everything we got to see
each other and just like that's right
like what you doing is we gonna get this
show moving when I talk about what the
Lord's are playing so what let's start
off with you do what are you playing
this way which means like we games in
Iraq mainly players are known
battleground and play a little bit of
Madden recently okay
tried a long shot I only been playing
all on like playing a guy I don't play
the campaign yet or the franchise or
whatever I didn't catch it did you beat
that hundred dollar thing I heart a good
one that now you want it
yeah yeah they're mad man that's was so
Lord addict what have you been playing
this week uh Mario in rebus that's
pretty much every day I've came home
this we got passed out to the scream
yeah no doubt and Lord King
what have we been rocking this week whoa
um sir Lord Benjamin Johnson my French
Bulldog came home so
definitely you know been acclimated you
know to the family but um
in between there I finished the halo
wars - now I gotta you know start
working on those little skirmishes and
stuff like that yeah that out um I
stopped playing the mad you get that
confidence up to play me oh you look
crushable - it's like looking at you
also Oh - rabbits oh I know I'm gonna
jump into Lord addict segments later so
I know you're talking about rabbits oh
that's gonna happen thrown the destiny
on a PC oh I got the 4k 80 frames per
second oh yes I was like beastin but I
stopped playing it Oh back off it stop
playing it and um I resigned to the fact
that I was definitely playing there on
my xbox platform because it's um I was
dead it was like playing on PlayStation
no just want you tell my first community
you know bots running around basically
you don't know if the real of fake
asking Chad if there's any online
aspects to merit + ramp as far as I know
new right it should be just it's I know
there's a co-op but I believe it's a
local co-op right Raj but attic yeah you
touched it yeah just go all right cool
nobody got to that part yet Langer
unfortunately yeah I know I saw your uh
your tweet loading in reference to which
you should pick up there and I know
America does have everything online so
if that's a factor for you yeah
Lord zero what have you been playing
this week a lot on finding games been
going back to MKX playing a bunch of
injustice and Dead or Alive
mystery man a lot with a panda from
after-hours bar Cadia which
you know he's very happy nobody heard
this was hashtag backlog and I got it
done
salute to my trainers Lord ain't addict
you see I was able to get that my first
championship and August at achieved
championship a very excited all those to
keep my school shout out to tell y'all
that it was those gay those really
really cheap game was my headshot Allah
Megatron it was a battle all the way up
to like the last three weeks challenge
me picking up cheap $2 things but we got
it done but um I also shall to rent I
don't know how you guys do that every
week every month it is intense to keep
1s so I will be retiring now that SD to
be coming in for another three years at
least I got my first one shout out to
make a chart to cash out after the
Winter Soldier see you
it's a we I don't know how you guys do
that everyone it is intense but I will
say this that's something I do which
like Nintendo does a corporate because
seeing that achievement leaderboard is
really fun because you wake up in the
morning like oh you know cut my score
down tonight cause I'm okay I kind of
move on so it was really fun but anyway
that's that and all just want to get in
real quick - last week's poll the road
results are in and the people have
spoken
so to the question your favorite
favorite favorite hunter in a very close
second place I mean we already see what
the people that spoke and we got a new
call all picking up on at the end of
show tonight so enough for that we're
gonna get into these topics so
unfortunately Mossad is not in today but
we're gonna keep his topic and we want
to talk about um the Xbox one X
pre-orders and that uh that's the ESCO
that's been going on well recently I
know that Michael Pachter has made some
comments and reference and actually want
to set this off with um Lord BG if it's
available because um I know he did a
recent video on this and reference to
the Brooklyn skill tree so uh well BG
have you been following this
all Fiasco about the Xbox 1x pre-orders
yeah talk to me about partying and
windows sensual and this little beef and
tell me what your feelings yeah so
pretty much like Packer was saying like
there's not the report from window
central that he disagrees with about it
being the most pre-orders but he was
pretty much saying like that doesn't
actually mean what you think like
because as far as pre-ordered Xbox
consoles there's really only been like
one I mean yes well well one official
launch I mean cuz we they were like you
know the reader reiterations like that
you know the xbox slim I guess you can
count that and the original Xbox 360 so
it has been like I guess maybe maybe 3d
the Xbox 360 the Xbox 360 slam and the
Xbox one and I guess the S because you
could have pre-ordered all those right I
think you could have pre-ordered all
those so I think pretty much what he was
saying like that it doesn't really mean
much as far as like being the most Xbox
pre-orders ever because there having
been in that many exactly absolutely I
mean it is I feel there's some truth to
it but I want to get the UH what the
rest of the lords are feel I know uh so
strong on this it's like you know do I
think people are blowing this out of
proportion yeah it's not like you know
they came out and said this is a limited
edition that they said from the start
it's going to be limited stock so
obviously it's it's it's hard to come by
when you got like 10 to every game
stopped and you know maybe Amazon has
5,000 let's obviously they probably got
more than that but you get the point
clearly you know this product will be
hard if you have it in small quantities
okay no uh Lord look King what's your
opinion on this whole I know you feel
strongly about that used to be having
any streets back it was crazy
yo used to be you as the digital foundry
back in the days I used to go and I used
to listen to you for your business
knowledge I was like man being a young
entrepreneur I was like no his
statistics he's on point but I realized
fact that you are biased dude like
spring phony
because every time PlayStation he does
something you just be bandwagon hopping
from this to that but I noticed I know
that you was down in them trenches when
you were getting beat down by the
Microsoft steam train over there
PlayStation you you had your flag your
feet flag was flying then buddy got
crushed so now that these dudes is up yo
hold a PlayStation the premotor Punk got
smash you got smashed and you upset
right now cuz your freak flag has got to
go down you gotta put it back in your
pocket is now that you don't wanna
change the narrative now not a narrative
gonna be oh at a PC standards cause it's
crushing your probe I know that's next
I'm sick and tired of every time these
guys get a small victory somebody want
to sit there try to snatch it away no is
the most Oh is the most pre-order system
the fastest pull order system and it's
smashing that Pro and smashing that
PlayStation stuff so understand take
that sit down relax take a breath and
just say yo let them have that
let this sunshine on them still got
sixty five minutes alright you're still
doing your numbers right what are you
afraid of I know you're afraid of bring
them back some bad memories will use
getting stomped in the back of yo hey
looky let me ask you good what about me
what about the argument that I'm hearing
the reference to like for example let's
just say I'm just doing a hypothetical
let's just say they had mm you know
marks of Xbox Scorpio like if it's the
number let's say that the actual number
is low but they're saying in this so
though you don't write you guys see
nowadays it's the way you word things
like launch exclusive
uh you know it will be like exclusive
they don't forget about that first part
launch
the only one who's paying attention to
that launch exclusive with the hardcore
game for week it will be out with you
guys first listen that whatever people
hold on to whatever to push the
narrative fine I don't care if they have
40,000 like he's saying they had 40,000
in the souls are clear what do you want
them I have two million perhaps two
million day one so stop it I'm pretty
sure if they had a larger number they
would have sold out at a larger rate to
switch did it to everybody does it so
don't don't sit there and try to snatch
away their little shine stop it I don't
like the rhetoric that you just not
feeling - I'm feeling the hate
as far as Patrick goes I never really as
far as the system's doing honestly the
man is the man and I'm just happy to see
that people want it okay because for the
longest time people were saying you know
nobody is gonna be interested in it
because like Ryder's said patches like
the weatherman usually wrong but still
has the job right I mean it - yeah the
friends looking I will say this that he
was one be an issue on forecasters that
actually said he doesn't see right yeah
I said price point and get Nick do you
feel like closer that like you're not
really still paying him no mom because
of this initial feeling I respect him as
a businessman you know he's made a
career and everything right foot his
predictions are usually wrong and this
is something like Lord Kiro down and
chat just now like I don't know why
people oh I don't know why people take
Packer as gospel most of his predictions
are wrong
when I thought I won't jump in real
quick I mean I thought the evening your
banter between him and Hamish after loss
Jes Gordon from windows central was kind
of interesting you know he actually
through window central under the bus
seems like don't believe that ish over
there you know there's been an apology
between those central I mean not just
blunt impact and he trying to basically
say like you know it was more of a shot
at the fanboys the Xbox fan boys know it
was a shot there was no that was
definitely a shot fired across the bow
you know in reference to that so I just
thought that part was interesting you
know me as far as the pre-orders and
snow you know who knows how much stock
they had you know but at the end of the
day you know whatever it was it you know
according to Microsoft it did sell out
so you have to take them work for their
word at it for nano obviously you know
the hard core in my opinion is going to
buy this system the question is is it
going to be enough to the November or is
it going to be enough to sustain past
that because we know the hard core are
going to most likely buy this thing so I
do got a question to ask everyone on the
family do you guys still think they have
a chance to win over yeah no way I feel
like this I'm part of the bendi said
what's up I'm gonna say no what
initially seeing Xbox so curious about
how he is now with this information
yeah in Italy I had said I definitely
feel they should win it but uh it's not
that crackdown was gonna help it win
right but it I felt like it wasn't gonna
hurt it but now the bad press the bad
press might might hurt them and cause
them to uh and can cause them to lose
November I'm not sure but um I think I
think like people might forget about
crackdown by then and the like just pick
one up anyway so I think I still had a
chance so you still think they still got
a chance in reference to it if if they
don't who you think would be the biggest
competition
you know to them regardless for that
month but it was only with the bundles
do you think it'll be switched with the
with the Mario or whatever who do you
think is the biggest competition telling
cuz such a tough month honestly I think
if Sony I don't I don't like Mario is
gonna sell but I think people are really
putting too much into this Mario like
they making it way too much of a force
when it's it's a force by this night
listen it's not more of a sports than
the PS boards no I think people were
more you know obligated to pick up
switch because there's multiple games
out now by the time Brad RTC comes out
and not necessarily because Odyssey is
coming out this mixed they say Sony with
the bun who summer since wish Jaz good
crazy did you think I don't think there
was gonna win November because of the X
I thought they was gonna win November
because of the s to be honest with you
tell me the combination of all Xbox
platform right that's how we looked at
it we didn't state it you know Xbox was
gonna wins just solely because of the X
I didn't think that I don't think they
have the numbers to do that um for the
system but I thought that s being that
you know the bundles the Black Friday
other sales the fact that they can lower
the price to the to the casual to walk
in and pick one up at a super low price
that wasn't looking at it I think need
to get Christmas out of the way I think
I think their biggest you know I think
the ps4 bundles is between more than
issue than the switch like I really
could when you're when you're promoting
you know the ps4 with battlefront Call
of Duty like that that could be destiny
well you know by then I think the did
the destiny you know ride would be calm
not dead but it yeah so I don't think a
whole lot of people or cuz you know a
lot of that by that time they'll be
destiny two bundles bought but I think
you only be you know the battlefront
the you know the Call of Duty's but you
know I want to know how Microsoft gonna
combat that because they've done stuff
in the past like you know let's say I
remember a Call of Duty came once out
like it was the 7th of November or
something like that and they now it's
like two weeks before that and only on
the it was like the 6th 7th and 8th if
you buy ATX you get a game for free to
log BG what did you base your an issue
prediction of Microsoft win in November
on well what what did you think was
gonna put them over the top earlier uh
just that I don't think it well it would
be the assumed price drop I assumed it
would be a price drop around that time
of the s and you know even though the
hardcore demographic is like a minority
it's still it's still a lot enough yeah
there's still millions a hardcore people
and people don't realize that yeah and
it's still a lot to help you just win
you know at least one month you know so
you get all of that you get those
combined forces then that should you
know on pay-per-view easy one at least
right now a little busy no doubt I did
see though I'm following you and I did
see when the crackdown delay happen you
fell back you were like I don't know I
might have to rescind this hey it's
gonna be a tough with that little beat I
got one last question for more to the
next topic because we here at the ILP we
have a second we do we call Ben we got
load it's all in fun we got Lord hip-hop
gamer in it you know we got we got a
little Rand in it don't want to see cuz
obviously November is a huge month right
everyone it's gonna be tight who's gonna
win this NTD good nor DG willing to
throw his name in the Hat independent
segment and be a man of his convictions
and say who's gonna win that November is
he doesn't owe us anything I'll actually
like confirm it like Popeye but
everything is just cuz hip hip hop is
saying what hip hop said on Xbox brand
Lord Ram he said switch with me also now
I mean I mean II love beat
part of this bed to be who's gonna bid
I'm uh November I'm uh I'm a double down
imma go xbox again I know that's it
really should be an easy bag I mean it
really should be easy
imma be really like if if Microsoft
can't pull this off then like they got a
lot more there in a lot more serious
[ __ ] than we think you know I feel the
same way you feel because I didn't base
my numbers I based it on you know
technically I knew that the X would sell
out
I know whatever initial allotment they
would have that would sell out so that
would boost those numbers but then it's
the back order you know the stock that
they do have and how are they gonna get
that to the masses of that's those
essence you know cuz fill one of solos
asses he wants you to forget about the
bad taste of the original Xbox and put
these s's in your house and you know to
push that 4k narrative you know um so I
really believe that the S is if they can
get it to that that sweet spot of like
179 with a game you know and then then
you get that Black Friday madness I
really think they have a shot it would
be great because what I want to do is
like I said come December we're not at
nothing else because I will will revisit
the beat hall with all the Lords that
have participated so that should be fun
so it is there's no real reason why they
should lose that like if Microsoft loses
November on this topic we're going to
move game has released that he's been
waiting a long time that have Abbott's I
believe so I'd like to say about this
what I'll give you a floor
so on the switch they I think I can't
even remember what I think was last
Tuesday they released Mario Plus rabbits
which I think that's that I've always
thought that is a stupid name
Mario Plus rabbits like I think they
could have found something else besides
up plus between their names like I'm not
REO and Revit you know I'm gonna go and
own this game okay I am so I played it
and I just I first awful want to ask the
panel has anyone else here played it
besides me I know I know you were
looking into it but I don't know if you
picked it up or not because I I got that
gift that you were kind of like you know
you were leading a life and switch no
I'm gonna get it eventually um like I
keep I know I keep pushing pushing it
back and back like when I'm gonna get
one but I will get one like it'll be in
the next few months but you know the
game it just I'll look through the rest
of the panel talk if they play it's the
greatest thing right now I mean all
right
maybe the Zelda has washed off for me
right now and I had to go back and put
the Zelda on so I checked out the Zelda
and graphics the graphics okay what I've
noticed with the Zelda it's soft it's a
softer look while Mario Plus rabbits has
a sharper more Nintendo Wii Mario they
captured the whole essence of Mario in
my opinion um with stuff being added to
the hub when you defeat things you go
back to the hubby you know the stuff
that wasn't there before and it's like
these little nuances these little
Nintendo isms that pop up that make you
you know feel like wow it's like my
first strategy type game like you know
cover base and and when you really delve
into it it is so intricate and so deep
how you set up a board and get past it
like it's different ways to do things
it's called influence it's so beautiful
yes the XCOM influence is heavy inside
the game it was a great merger of the
two and the cambio oh my god the the the
meepo um
functionality of everything there was
music it wasn't over you
it was if you had these set of me bowls
you can use them one time and then you
get a weapon for that but the weapon is
not Opie actually by the time you unlock
it even if you unlock it that second the
weapon that you get is really is
inconsequential oh let me ask a question
will Kings I know you're an amiibo my
question is no it's a one time using one
shot is it a daily use like house lb
long day okay so with just one and
that's it that's it you just get that
one done and you can never go back to
the me will store again actually it's
good for the one shot there you know
just to get the hundred percent out the
game because some people is a
completionist type of game you would
like to go back and finish some of the
challenges and some of the challenges
are super hard and it looks great my
children watch me play it constantly my
son could be in his room playing Batman
or whatever he is that Mario Plus
rabbits come on he runs downstairs to
watch so it's a fantastic game it looks
great it's probably to me and saying
this knowing that Muriel carcass out
right and Zelda is out it's probably to
me the most visually arresting game that
they have on a system so far in my
opinion actually I played it for a
little bit I did I didn't I know how I
hit first of all I'm a huge ex-convict
that's like one of my favorite games of
all time so when I heard about this
announcement you know Mario Plus rabbits
and Ubisoft first I was impressed that
Nintendo even allowed Ubisoft to do
something like this with one of their
franchise so that was the first thing
the second thing I'm like alright let me
see the XCOM aspect of it and I want to
see how deep it really is because we all
know an ex home is very deep so I was
actually surprised like it's like South
America in a chat it's a very aggressive
XCOM you know like XCOM is more about
you're moving couple spots moving couple
spots overwatch you know move your guy
here so you're trying to flank the enemy
if they react to you where this is more
like you
throw your man over there to jump to a
logic distance to go get them dudes kind
of game really aggressive a little bit
of an adjustment not a bad thing but um
yes so far I mean I've been like you
know Bob I'm gonna take 1/3 oak you know
like that in play too long cuz I know
how I am with those type of games I tend
to please
and um shout-out to a lord at it because
I've been playing some other stuff on
the switchboard owner I like it so far
it's a different tape you know I think I
know what our Lord addicts
problem with the game is I'll let him
talk on it but so far so good you know I
want to get deeper in it I've got
cinematics are fun I didn't expect the
only type of great story with this game
I mean it's really mixing apples and
oranges so the fact that they even had a
cinematic to me in the beginning trying
to explain why these characters are in
the same leg I was like okay I get it
like I'm not here for that I'm here for
the ExComm business I like I know you
not have a sweet yet but on did you um
at least you know see anything about it
that interests you or is it something
that as a switch if you get a switch get
or not get it looks interesting it has
my attention I didn't want to comment I
agree with you where you said you're
surprised that you've soft you know let
something like that happen one their
titles right yeah um have y'all seen the
Final Fantasy
lore BG I know you said this was one of
the games your next comm guy correct on
the phone oh yeah I mean I'm a you so
ex-con fan and everything so what what
excites me about this is that like it
opens Nintendo up to doing other games
finally good like because all I want
them to do was like copy the genre of
other games that I like with men you
know just use their own characters
instead of just continue making
platformers of everything they have so
that's what excites me about Lord addict
I know you got some things to say I saw
your Twitter timeline and so you would
Erica go at it this is one of the
switches best games but you know I'm not
gonna just like give them a complete
pass on everything that's just game has
to offer if you come into this as a big
fan of XCOM and you know you you expect
you know pretty much an X Y X Comics
parent playing this game you're gonna be
sadly mistaken it's got an ex-con
filling but do not expect this is gonna
be like ex-con in a way it's way more
simplistic than X combo and another like
in the exact same way it's it's what
they make it simplistic they keep you
know the difficulties still there
because on this game you know an ex-con
you can get upgrades to upgrade to get
more people in your squad and you start
with four people on X come on this it's
3 & 3 only sometimes they can they can
overrun you very easily and if you don't
it's more of those things where they
reward they reward you for being
aggressive and if you're not aggressive
they they'll hurt you tremendously so is
there no like uh defensive techniques in
that light for what enemies approach
there's no overwatch like stander
but there are all buildings for Allah
watch there are abilities for overwatch
and you know one of the issues I have
with the game is you know I understand
you know with Laura carnitas said about
the story but my issue it's like not
even really I expected a huge deep story
but I feel like there's too much you
know there's not enough explanation when
you're playing this game it's like oh go
to the go to the graveyard place you go
to the grave you it's they they don't
really explain what's going on like at
all it's like you spend if you literally
don't like this is not gonna be one of
those things to bring in from another oh
no no no no because you start the game
it starts off really good like it really
does like when you start it off it has
like that Blizzard with overwatch
feelings he keeps think of each other
about all that
to the game of the year 2016 we are not
talking about that so you know in
travesty at the point one of the issues
I had it didn't make it really I feel
like you know one of the reasons that a
lot of media hadn't thought this game
was hard is because as their bums see on
this they not only do they not reward
you for you know playing bad get a bad
moves in in game you do not get you
don't recover after games and there's
some times where you go section after
section after session with the exact
same amount of health right without
that's what makes their difficulty what
their difficulty is sometimes I would
literally have to stand back and you
know play defensive and he'll owe as
many of them as I could before the the
enemies talk to me because I couldn't
just he'll you know if you if you come
across a corner and get hit by the
people with a little the ice cube things
they did tremendous damage and they
could come out of nowhere and then if
you killed him and then you went to the
next game Mario got 20 HP for the next
match didn't necessarily mean it was
hard you know it just meant you have to
played more you know cautiously but I
was just I thought I'm not I'm not
disappointing to the game I think for
the game
what that was my next question for I was
like based on now that you've played a
bit you know are you disappointed or you
feel it all leveled up the wrong
abilities because there's no issues at
all playing the game well going to
different segments from different
segments the people that I have in my
party cuz you able to switch out people
in your party people that you have in
your party are able to heal your party
so strategically if you're playing in a
fashion that heals your party as you go
every time you go to the next segment
you don't have an institute I know I
don't even fall into that category
anymore because I do so much vampire
healing on self hill on my characters
and using weapons then on vampire heals
peaches splash abilities yeah I use that
splash ability as well once I got her
but
for then I was using a lot of vampire
but no character I mean it's it's like I
said you know that I said media I didn't
say I fell in that category but I
started that segment with a lot I think
a lot of the reason the media thought
this game was hard cuz that's all you
saw when this game was being reviewed
it's hard it's hard it's hard it's game
they keep looking for a kids game and
it's not a child's game and there's no
difficulty level right no it is actually
before you start each match you can play
on the difficulty level that they give
you which is hard or you could play it
on easy as an easy button and it doubles
your energy to double so like if
children are playing they can press Y to
get past it so you don't get frustrated
with the game you know Nintendo's not
trying to shut up anymore
they should put Ironman and then make
them early cry but you know I got a
questions that y'all played it and I
have it and I really don't have any clue
is like this is a difficulty fuel earned
or does it ever feel artificially
difficult if that makes sense like
default to vote for the reason of being
is when you come across new enemies and
you don't necessarily know what they do
that's the only time the games hard at
all and even when that's not hard you
know it my Mario can kill five people in
one turn like he's ridiculously Opie
like you could - hit someone do 40 then
yeah - she's ope let me tell you real
quick like what's different from XCOM is
that like you know I like Exim you can't
really run on a space and a character
like with this you can run into the
space of the character and that'll be a
move to actually do damage like it's
I've never seen that before and the cool
part which I like is like I guess that
you can run into someone run back to
your spot then you can actually put your
character on your another or companion
character spot and he
throw you an additional space like no
knobby gets worse this is wild Opie you
know it gets worse you can vote - things
you can upgrade the dashboard does more
damage you can run to your person jump
and you can throw Mario on another enemy
more damage you can shoot and then you
can also put this power on Mario that if
they move his special move is overwatch
which is broken
Mario rabbit is broken really because he
is the most old P character in the game
his gun his gun game he has a gun then
if you shoot you it turns you to stone
right 90% of the time thing is to get
Muriel behind the strongest character
rabbit Mario shoot him turn him the
stone and just have everybody have at
this duel and get them out of their room
like you know what I meant yesterday
when I was talking on Twitter is like
you know I wasn't expecting a detailed
story I wasn't what I was expecting to
understand why I'm going to be certain
regions it's like they don't you an
overall objective they're like go find
the rabbit dude that's turning what your
objective is it's finding the rabbit
that's turning everything into what it
is and you literally I have like 10
hours in this game and I have not
changed that objective like way too much
for Mario you know it's the biggest like
just captain save oh like
like that I would just say you know a
different subjective message than going
from one point to fight one point
talking about transitions and reasonings
of why yeah I mean that's still too much
I'm so upset they're people that join
your fight or they're like okay it's not
like you had the freedom and then they
become part of your team anyway if
you've been talking to him and they
decide to show up and fight through now
you get your butt kicked too bad let me
join you you run into a new person and
they throw someone that you know let's
say that you put all your time in a
we're gonna do we're gonna take object a
the dude you put everything into and
throw in you gotta use them you can this
is one is one part nobody's talking
about okay I put everything into that
same person two things that you don't
really like and then it's a segment
where you like all right let's do this
battle and it Blake now hold a second
throw your man to the corner you like
what and they give you the next person
that you know nothing about the ability
the abilities are not my child
they bilities this fresh face and they
like it work that out work that's like
when RPGs like you know for for a
segment or for story reason they make
you fight with at least like one
character you can't take out your party
yeah well like what is this like this is
the how for my team the game is awesome
it is a like
you know I like how aggressive this game
is that's why they give you three people
sometimes I you know I got to the this
one area where and I like that they give
object to five missions in this they're
like it's not just kill everyone it's
not just do this it's like yo we're
gonna race you over here get you from
point A to point B and you I like that
you know the the changing things up I do
like that did you play any of the
challenges because I got to the
challenge
it is so phenomenal they wants you to
get from the beginning to the board to
the we've told you ten times thank you
the end of the board but they want you
to do it in one term mm-hmm
gotcha all your tricks of the trade
sliding into characters using your
character bounce off a character using
their character to bounce off the next
character to get to the end of the board
this is possible because you probably
look at him like that's impossible
so this we got it off the Lords are good
on us which wraps fully move on we're
actually bringing since we're on the
subject of grandpa Nintendo here wanted
to uh bring in actually me to the
roundtable as far as the UH
revelation had happened last week two
players they were able to have this
thing set up through a local area Newark
interesting because as the fans BLP know
Lord kicking I have good at this subject
which was announced I said there's no
possible that this system cannot do
native in voice chat I mean Game Stop
had a listing for a it's
so I'm like wait that's it now we did
hear about this foolish app and well I'm
like you know what this is Nintendo
conventional wisdom just says this is
just an option right so as the news came
forward and Lord King began to laugh at
me as more information became de facto
Falls like they're not that dumb but
surely they're not bad pause knows he's
with the times voice chat is something
that every system but even their system
so as it became known in this
announcement came out and obviously the
jokes in the means went down that this
stupid app is mandatory and like Lord
addict says if you're on a call
something happens you get bumped from
the app you get a text you get bumped
from me so I thought this was quite
humorous one we've media that are they
found out that there's fully functional
voice chat in the middle it is stable so
what this has shown as that grande
partying window is purposely long con oh
yes continues looking how do you get
that functionality out I don't know how
they found out about this what do we
think about this one
you can only do you have to be like a is
this like a bug or Nintendo purposely
designed it so you can only have voice
chat on the same Wi-Fi now just like a
loophole note if it's a loophole it
purposely break into the system that
they can do it they have blocked the
ability to do voice chat unless you do
it yeah this is purpose oh is this a
thing with Justin Tendo game Jenner or
just with splatoon they test it on Mario
Kart 8 and they said that the
functionality that it was really bad so
is one of those things that it is being
blocked the abilities dead but it's
beating block I what I need to know this
lucky but what so the next part
understand so if this was a feature
intentionally that's supposed to be
there yes why did why did players have
to discover it why was exactly you know
why they had to discover it because it
was stupid it was stupid to say you
listen you could you could do voice chat
if we all sitting in the same room Oh
stupid head he just said why don't we
just take the headset off but what if
Tommy has to go to the bathroom
alright well leave it in there as a
Chico but we're not gonna talk we can't
advertise so you actually you really
have to put in
in I was joking I thought the tool and
play which is accomplished by going into
the games lob serve you hold down and
the are buttons and the left stick
waiting for this to fade to initiate
local area network play and built-in
voice chat that is officially in sight
right now they got the cold out this had
to be like this had to be them like
working on something initially in the
last minute yeah and then they cut it
and but they like didn't cut it out all
the way this couldn't have been in send
this had to be like yo yeah we gonna put
this in and we we dropping this but we
ain't gonna remove the feature for the
input coke it nobody ever gonna figure
that out
unfortunately the quality of the chat is
riddled with static interference and
initially comes out and is really stupid
so that's it but I guess what I wanted
to also talk about is that like when I
hear stuff like and I say okay and the
only thing I can think about it is like
they are still they still must be in
this archaic mentality that we have to
protect the kids
John I'm saying because why are you
forcing this app so hard and the other
question I have for the arm round thing
is that do you think because of the
negative backlash at this app is it's
been killed everywhere I mean even the
the most conscious Nintendo supporters
of sites have gone in on this app
because of public pressure and the fact
that the actual online service will
launch next year do you think there's
any chance that they would try to
initiate a work on some type of native
voice chat Helena they can't
that's what the app is for I know they
can zero I think you have a better
chance to get in Sony to do cross play
than you have Nintendo doing this
negative voice chat unearthed yes I
haven't laughed and my brain works even
if it is only Wi-Fi rate this shows it's
like my it's like Nintendo is like you
know what I think we can dominate this
whole generation what you know
technically I like how people compare
the switch to the Xbox one it's like
technically the switch is the generation
above the Xbox one and the ps4
you couldn't even it's like ps4 and the
Xbox one already stomp their there eight
generations so you can't even really
make that comparison but if you do want
to it's like they're we're gonna beat
the competition but you know what we
feel so confident ourselves let's make
us have handicaps people like to talk to
each other so let's take that Adam let's
make this is something I couldn't I
refuse they don't have voice chat they
need to sell every switch with a PSN
card or an Xbox one line of work
[Laughter]
- this is quite humorous PlayStation VR
streets get rid of my PlayStation VR
yes with you I played all my games you
know purchase every game they had for it
and you know I was just sitting there
like wild hey this is you know low
Cognito wrist is ugly head again crap
and he talked that he talked it into
existence and they aren't supporting
this I literally said let me pack this
stuff up and get it get it out of the
door I was gonna probably put it on eBay
because you know I don't support games
it doesn't matter so I said okay let me
let me get rid of this thing and
literally I think was minutes later
Laura Cognito sends me a text shot you
that three flew on a baseline I was like
oh
I said oh hello um PlayStation announced
release dates for the most sought after
games for the VR and more VR support I
guess it was in a parish show or
something and then I looked at the games
that were coming out I say you
I was interested in these games I played
them all at e3 this is my thing you know
I go and I test all the VR games because
I know once people get a chance to fill
that medium to put a face inside them
goggles there's not purchased a VR it's
inevitable it's gonna happen because
it's like candy once you get a taste of
it you like you know you're gonna have
that sugar rush all the time you don't
want it um so I unpacked all my stuff I
said thank you to uh needle then I said
is this the point with Sony turns it
around with the VR narrative did they
get they stock up or something because
something seems to be wrong with the
progression of the TR on the PlayStation
VR it's something when more is a
disconnect there to sell 60 million plus
systems and this is part of your link
and nobody's in this lane on the console
other than yourself why is it this thing
being talked about and championed BG did
you get a chance to play playstation vr
I hate PlayStation VR I hate all the VR
as quick as Microsoft Kinect I'm still
seeing a VR games come out like actual
relevant VR games come out now but I
just personally hate VR because it makes
me sick yes made me sick almost almost
died at e3 you tried it and you suffer
from I did you get it when you sit down
in the games did you play any sit-down
games or was it the for the standing
games along oh yes that down us you know
stood up it didn't matter to me it was
Bo I play a play like doom VR I played
uh Riggs or some else up play all of
them made me sick Wow yeah a lot of
people feel the same way the vertigo I
mean I jump in real quick um I obviously
I had to shoot my bad little King that
bone on that cuz I was surprised I was
like well they actually still support
still making stuff for it the only thing
I've changed me is because I'm such a
fan boy was the the vulture of er
chronicles what literally once you send
me that yeah
unpack my stuff so I say when that come
out I said Lord King you sent me to
invite I'm coming to the crib and I'm
definitely won't give it a chance to see
because I still have not touched I'm
very what a game I didn't look mother
in your defense is that I really need to
experience it I really needed to get
into it stuff like that I guess I'm part
of that whole connect error still
thinking some of these things of
gimmicks and then with the install base
you know not everyone adopting it so
it's like how much are they really gonna
support it but I am surprised that you
know Sony still continue to put now
games not a question I have for you lo
King is are they armed I are a woman are
they dropping the price on the psvr no
whoa all the ARS across the board have
been dropping the price survive drop the
price oculus you know we know oculus and
the financial troubles have dropped the
price all of them have dropped the price
because they're trying to get it to the
point where it's viable for people to go
inside and purchase right now it's not
viable is that a premium price rate and
it keeps people out the PlayStation is
the most cost-effective but I believe
that they're taking it at a loss I
honestly believe that to get that level
of VR to the house that they're probably
making $2 if not losing $2 on every
system I'll pass it a little bit it did
a decent immersion but I just I've still
to this day you know maybe after I get
my hands on a ps4 and then shortly I
will not shortly hell no not shortly
after that I get my hands on a VR then
you know I have been told there's a lot
of games in there that not only do they
have immersion in it but they actually
are good yeah I'm gonna play these quote
good uncle games as of right now it's
like people were like are you
final fantasy fan go fishing yeah okay I
would not recommend that but I'm gonna
tell you this stay the hell away from
resume I'm late I already scary sound
like I heard ads yeah that's that's
intense the first game on play like
there's a couple I see that game was
jump scares more than actually like
shiver down your spine ski got me to
where I was like oh you want to go any
further there was a couple couple scenes
from beer that made me feel like that
and the original dead space made me feel
like that zero what's your feeling on
the situation yeah they just don't do
nothing for me oh yeah it's just not my
kind of thing you know I don't knock the
people like for all those division
players is millionaire division players
out there VG 24/7 gave a whole rundown
on the new patch 1.0.8 yes correct yes
and before after this no one point seven
has been out this is my eight 1.8
supposed to loss one point eight is
supposed to launch sometime in the fall
I don't believe they gave an actual date
all right I thought you'd be soft was
trying to decide
in theory because you know train is too
big they would do it like one is a low
so they probably do it in November or
something like that but um the PvE mode
is for resistance and the PvP mode is
for thermos
the the resistant mode is more like the
hard mode so I'm a bit so once you say
what it's about just out of curiosity
just cuz I'm kinda like the Horde kind
of like the prison of elders type and
thing you know they're they're taking a
little bits and pieces of destiny and
added and in there they change in the
system a little bit they give you more
guns and everything man monkey play me
and hot monkey love a shout out the hot
monkey love and me and I play every day
all right me bostonia hot monkey love
him and then a couple other guys did you
ever play that BG's what you said the
division I play the demo I tried to
convince myself to like it I couldn't
cuz I remember when the PS shows the ps4
demo came out yes and then and then I
was like yeah I can't get jiggy with
this and then yes and then the pc demo
came out and I'm like maybe this changed
my mind
like now I can't get jiggy with this
either
[Laughter]
[Music]
but the PvP mode is falling for so you
can get in confined spaces and get um
that Osiris on now what I've noticed is
they're taking cues from destiny that
what work with destiny and they
implementing it inside the game and the
reason why they're able to implement it
with just patches and updates and open
up boards is because they're not held
back by the older systems so the same
way that they're doing this
I think destiny 2 will be free from the
shackles of the PlayStation you know 3
and the 360 they able to open up and
give us more stuff the stuff that we was
looking for so it was well for with
these new games let me ask you a
question before you move on looking I am
surprised though that they actually are
still updating it because I thought at
this point they'd be like ok I'm
investing he's obviously our opposition
our competition I thought that they
would kind of be gearing up for that
differential brief yes these are free
updates huge updates I guess my question
to you is are you sir are you more happy
with this continued support or do you
rather than put those resources in
Africa's game I don't honestly I don't
think a division 2 comes out for the
next three years probably because
they're able to expand the existing game
by giving you DLC that opens up the map
they don't actually really need a whole
new game because the graphics the
graphics are damn good mom the game is a
good 2 great game depending on your
level of playing
yeah it has his issue but he defends the
game because the gear fault is year
ahead better than destiny you know we
listen to Destiny's community and
destiny
she listens to the community and they
actually go on any fix but they take
longer than you bespoke Ubisoft actually
their turnaround so you know the major
problems it's really fast right you know
we complain about preload outs now
you're able to preload out existing
characters that you didn't have to jump
out a switch you know how we zone we
switch our characters in space and and
destiny we have to change and we have to
loadout no you're able to actually jump
now we were you have to do that before
now you're able to do it in game switch
our characters so they fix all our
problems and they're working on total to
get to a perfect game it's now gonna be
perfect for everyone but if you go back
now to the division opposer when you
first played it it's a totally different
game game let me know at one point am i
jumping at home and a lot of news in
these destiny streets um lot of stuff to
talk about so I wanted to bring this to
the roundtable hopefully we don't put
the BG completely asleep but oh yeah
basic that's digital foundry had came
out with a very intense article right
now that has my Twitter line going crazy
and he talked about um 1080p60 and what
it would take for a destined to be run
at that rate I also want to talk about
besides that there's the weekly update
they also talked about um when the
actual raid would be released on destiny
- I believe it's the 13th and trials of
Osiris it will be coming back on the
15th and then the last thing is aam boy
there's been a ton of leaks if the the
dams have been breaking just about next
people are leaking stuff all over the
place
we got curse of Osiris DLC we got all
type of leaks going on so before we
start with all that stuff I want to
start with the digital foundry the
technical stuff first now on Lord eg I'm
gonna start with you um did you get a
chance to find out what was going on
with this uh whole 1080p60 our destiny
to statistics what CPUs can run it I
don't know if you got a chance to check
that out yeah I actually
I really look that much into it I was I
was hearing more about the whole
aim-assist thing on yeah what the day
well first of all you you play first
role you played the PC version correct I
play both you okay now on tell me what
was your external net the biggest
destiny guy but what was your
experiences from a graphical fidelity
standpoint how did it look to you how
did it feel to you and I honestly feel
like I feel like for people who are
diehard destiny fans you can no longer
call yourself a dial our destiny family
playing on consoles I really feel like
it's not any Ti okay I 747 9 TK 16 years
right
um but yeah I feel like I just feel like
it's the equivalent to like maybe like
you know I don't know you uh you a
baseball fan but you got like the
craziest nosebleed seats you can't
really call yourself a fan you not
really watching the game well is it
gonna be 16 it's not going me 60 frames
no it's the 60 frames that make the
difference man like yeah
destiny is probably the if I'm not
mistaken the only first-person shooter
that's not 60 frames yep that's what
again if you now let me let me bring
this to your attention
Lord BG because this is what's a hot
point of contention at digital foundry
just put out an article our good friend
Richard Ledbetter put out a good thing
as far as CPU um as far as 1080p60 and
what we need to run so basically in his
article he basically said that the ps4
is 1.6 gigahertz CPU can handle 30
frames with some overhead to spare and
he said logic suggests that you'll be
requiring more than a 31 percent
increase in processing power to run
everything at double speed which rules
out the ps4 Pro as far as the 60 frames
per second but he said the xbox 1x hands
in a 44% increase in CPU power but again
she said it doesn't seem like anywhere
enough brute force to get the job done
so he said in terms of his PT test and
he said they regret that they didn't
have an AMD Jaguar CPU core for testing
because obviously that would be closest
baseline to what the Xbox one ex is
doing you know what
CPU so basically what I wanna bring to
you long BG specifically because I know
you're the PC guy is that I've been
seeing a lot of talk in these Twitter
streams and um I got a shot him out cuz
this is my man there's no personal beef
Lord reg right right you know he's
basically saying like you know he's a
it's embarrassing right now that these
consoles especially Xbox one expert
particularly can't run the 60 frames per
second my argument has been more so that
you know as much as we're touting the
Xbox one acts as a beast right and that
GPU right people are forgetting about
the CPU and the CPU computations and
what it can handle
he said I'm saying so my question you
lower B gia in reference to that do you
think that it's one of these things
where it's you know the developer is
being lazy Bungie being lazy do you just
feel that look it just can't handle it
like what's your gut telling you in
reference to this whole destiny to 60
frames-per-second fiasco
I don't think it's uh at the Xbox 1x
can't handle it I think that they're
choosing to make a game that can do 4k
instead of 60 frames the point there's
good points missed where their priority
is because you know it's all about
marketing you can't really it's hard to
market 60 frames mm-hmm like high you
know you can't you can't put 4k on above
60 frames on a box and like okay you
know and even even casuals they'll still
see 4k they don't got to know that much
casual see 4k on a box and you know that
game and that means something to them
but 60 frames to a casual doesn't really
mean much so that's why and it's part
it's partially the game of communities
fault that they emphasize rebel
resolution so much so and this in the
Xbox one X is just Microsoft's console
of saying okay well this is yacht talk
to all that [ __ ] so now they made this
console no so it's so you know and
that's what it is if it's it's
definitely capable of sixty frames
it's just what do you want to sacrifice
to get those 60 frames do you want
maybe downscaled you know the the scope
of the game a little bit maybe downscale
these graphics to 60
James mm-hmm but you know if you want to
do that you can do it but that's not
what they want to do that's not what
Microsoft you know really you know it's
not what one last question before I pass
to the rest of the roundtable to you on
obg in reference to that now we've seen
with things like rise of the Tomb Raider
right that's just been announced for the
Xbox one next where they have this
moment where they have the 4k
you know Moe 4k 30 and they have that
you know 4k whatever then they also have
a 1080 60 mode you know would be more
keen to see Microsoft adopt these type
of strategy as far as giving more
options almost kind of similar to a PC
innocence now if you're never gonna have
the extent of the PC but right you know
having a 1080 60 mode do you think they
need to accomplish that more as opposed
to pushing you know a 4k yeah I'm
honestly not sure as to why are there
any like confirmed games that we know of
that uh are gonna have optional
um right now rise of the Tomb Raider is
the first and only one that I know that
has the option wait does they have the
tank and I think that's a problem
especially first party wise because
there's at least three three three
Sony first party games that has
graphical options I know neo has it
he'll blade he'll blade has it right and
even even which we call it a horizon has
it doesn't make the game 60 frames but
with neo it definitely makes the game 60
hell-blade it makes the game it makes
the game 60 versus 30 so I don't I don't
know especially when they have that
power they can definitely create those
options I don't know how much more
manpower hours that required for them to
put those options in those games but
people definitely appreciated it because
I I was a like I turned the 60 Hertz
option off and hell-blade and it was
damn near unplayable like it was it
seemed it was like motion blur crazy and
delicious and I hate motion blur so it
would you know it was bad so I don't
know why they don't have those options
and more of those other games noticed
that the list shows a lot of games that
has the 60 frames per second and then
the options too
to the 1080p you know 60 oh well they
think is 1440p and 60 frames per second
and you know performance mode 4k mode
checkerboarded mode
you know those modes will be available
across the the boards any game that's on
the PlayStation that I've noticed so far
that I have those options already
built-in and it's on a multi-platinum be
inside the Xbox one next because you
know they're already Hilton into the
interface as far as you know first party
games we'll see um we know that they do
a lot of their first party games that
have achieved the 4k 60 frames per
second I have first party games to have
these options this is true this is true
you can't have a lot of cancel games and
expect to have games right um but the
games that they are telling you that you
know any game had an uncapped frame rate
that's backwardly compatible will
achieve the optimal frame rate of that
with no problem so again it could be 50
frames per second could be 60 frames per
second but those options to be there
once we get that beast within hand we
can see exactly where it's at how it
goes and everything is a bunch of
speculation now but the same way the pro
needed that that breathing room and the
beginning to - okay because that's a lot
of those stuff was added after the fact
it wasn't um you know built in you know
you got a game and later on you got a
pen
Oh bull smoke okay so Microsoft is
coming from behind and they're seeing
the mistakes ahead and hopefully they
can adagios pitfalls and you know put
those implementations into games where
60 frames if we scream loud enough 60
frames will be there for certain games
some games you just can't achieve 60
frames got you lured addict I need you
in this was will you at with this
information was 1080p 60 testing to I
think the reason that there's not a
1080p sixties because I do think they're
trying to keep a parity for the original
Xbox one
and I think that's the culprit I don't
think it's some marketing do you know I
do think the marketing them I have a
little bit say something to say on it
because you know you don't you
definitely don't what's the word I'm
looking for
I mean this is the hand of bite the hand
that feeds you you know Sony definitely
given out that money
Microsoft ain't giving out that money
simple you know I will say to your point
I'll give it right back to you is that
um obviously we know the relationship
Activision right now has with Sony in
reference to the marketing deals I don't
want to go as far as saying that that's
has a direct influence on platform
priority and then obviously we know
Microsoft has said please my could
borrow has that had okay I don't think
that's gonna prevent you know annex
supported game but I do think that's the
reason that they're not even commenting
that well they see that's the key
they're not commenting I'm with you on
this one I because I feel that I don't
think a marketing video would prevent a
system from having the better version
but I do find it interesting it's out to
four guys with quarters they had a good
discussion on this latest podcast you
know I do feel that it is kind of weird
that they're not being able to talk
about it right you noticed that like you
have no information or the Xbox the next
version of destiny to own what it can do
in any capacity so I'm not just any by
the way it's calling any Activision game
they're not seeing what the Xbox one
every time that's brought up in any kind
of meeting so they completely dodged the
question right that is correct so what
do you feel about that aspect Lord BG as
far as um marketing deals having any
effect do you feel it's BS you can't
even fall in today we're yeah I'm kind
of torn on whether like marketing deals
is is difficult because it's like I
think it's it I think it's the optics of
it mm-hm
that that work more than the actual is
this not the optics of making this game
seem like it's yours mmmh facts so you
know but other than other than that I
don't think like marketing deals I don't
think they're bad or anything some
people look down upon I mean I think
it's business baby we got to get that
money you it's competition right like
your pings whether what's funny is is
people always preach we need competition
and when they do [ __ ] for competition we
don't need marquee that's a theory I
mean it's the same thing I've fallen in
line with it exclusives I mean it's part
of the game if you want people to buy
your platform you've got to do this and
as far as marketing deals you know that
way unlike us where the hardcore we know
destiny to is also on the Xbox one X but
to the casual he sees a commercial he
sees a destiny to inspired PlayStation
console he may think that you can only
get destiny there so I can't get mad at
me for doing that it's like we're really
trying to trick the consumer into you
know thinking that's an exclusive it's
to you know you see that like you said
you see that it's it's about that
association with the brand you see ps4
at the end of every destiny to you so
destiny to looks good and when your
friends talk about getting destiny to
you know they they've triggered that ps4
brand with that destiny to so before you
know three or four people picking up his
because I honestly feel if I don't think
Sony needs a destiny marketing deal
right let's say they didn't have it I
think it would it would obviously still
sell the most on ps4 like the vast
majority I honestly feel Sony just does
this to have like a chokehold yes on I
feel like they do it more to not letting
Microsoft have it then they we we want
this that much no we just don't want you
to have I call it the boot on the neck
yeah we got we got all the market share
and you know what we just gonna take as
much as we can just make it harder for
you that's all it is right to be fit did
Microsoft do that to them the last
generation right because all the duty in
360 so turnabout's Fair Play
but uh we got a detain 1860 I want to
get into real quick the UM the leaks the
weekly update real quick obviously we
know about that raid which is one of the
biggest things in destiny it has been
announced to be thirteen so it looks
like we got a week to get those light
levels up to blaze to get that going and
the question I have is anybody seen
these leaks that's been going on staying
away from everybody stay away all right
there's one I cared about bring us love
you I love you I am NOT a fan of the
speaker I've been enlightened and the
speaker is a charlatan so when I heard
about the curse of Osiris DLC in
December when we go rescue my man the
great prophet I was excited
Lord zero I give you a flow where did
you feel about this DLC release it as
far as the League City be careful with
these leaks don't do anything there's
it's hard to dance around it to be
honest this cos everything's been rather
specific and kind of you know in detail
which is unusual but you'll see where it
goes to be honest I know for a fact
Cognito has been preaching the good word
of Osiris for years now that's going as
far as what the leaf contain I'll just
go over real quick I won't give any
details hasn't really been any story
information which is good not nothing
like too big the light cap has leaked as
well as the soft cap which is the
furthest who don't know the caffeine
gets you on your light level before you
have to grind the in-game stuff to get
to that
ashlynn yes those have leaked so has the
normal level kept you know distant like
in destiny boy you just got the level 20
and then you go from there um at least
50 exotic weapons and armours have
leaked class specific and not I don't
think game modes have really leagues
there's been some hints at what's gonna
be containing and raid the shots have
been linked to like complete and other
like chops just altogether and you know
what like I don't even this who they
need a fine like Lord BJ the reason all
this [ __ ] got leaked is because someone
got their hands on a strategy guide
before the game a strategy guide like
that is the worst thing your game could
possibly get leaked is a strategy yeah I
mean it's out there is coming next week
so this is to be expected but a lot Lord
addict you've been staying away there is
keeping particularly don't want to have
the whole games for because some
douchebag got his hands on a strategy
got things just to build a high pop up
six days before comes out but people so
[ __ ] before it supposed to sometimes I
was talking to one of my eat one of the
e3 I went to I think it was prema pretty
much ready to guys I was like they were
there and I always wondered like how
does it work that they get every bit of
information and put into you strategies
I'm like the
just clear the game yourself and figure
it out they're like not the developers
tell them everything yeah the develop a
said the developers like they talk with
somebody at the studio they they they
play the game themselves figure out
something but developers pretty much
tell them everything they know imagine
doing the strategy you got for like a
Skyrim with these guys because the tax
rate just to these books these strategy
guys and the systems is really high you
know as you know you know remember we
used to have game facts game facts kind
of is doing this thing still out there
but for those people that want that you
know that strategy guy in hand like I
got one for Zelda and it just enhanced
the game you know the game there's a
whole lot better for me having a
strategy got guy getting those little
nooks and crannies out of it the
playtime is bounded so yeah I think I
think it's good that the developers will
work hand in hand with our primer to
promote to get that stuff out to the
people I wonder how that whole process
works though like like who gets the
money what kind of deal evades like he
could that's interesting I didn't even
know about that some glycol PG brought
that to my attention as far as how their
daddy information is transpired I had no
idea that's interested real quick or
Lord King and Lord addict what did you
first feel about that a crucifix honesty
up see them both to kill each other in a
battle I don't the rescuing of mark
Cerny oh my I do see the restaurant of
mark Cerny was fantastic I think I think
to get that charlatan that snake oil
salesman
I think you should be able to put them
to death but the words Oh put him into
the prison of elders to save more
clarity free copy enact - so you can
take both of them and put them in the
I'll be with you there that the rescue
man but technology captured but we're
not gonna let's wrap this thing up some
great topics hang on actually first was
shot a lot B G for coming through man it
really really appreciates you coming
through and now he's dropping it Jim
Jim's honest right quick
so actually before we do our shows and
all that stuff I wanted to get wild
people out and this is what it's going
to be so based on what we talked about
earlier when new titles are announced in
Xbox one X game specs are revealed to
not hit the for case if the frames per
second target
who do you subject the most plain a lazy
developers not taking the time to
optimize for the architecture of the
Xbox one X or B Xbox in Microsoft's
themselves for creating an uncompromised
for cane area that is the question those
are the choices please Rock the Vote it
will be up on the ILP Twitter polls when
it goes up so first of all getting shot
the lobby g-man thank you for coming
through bro really appreciate you
traveling gemstone we can we can define
people find you what the wheel on
Twitter just look up weapon wheel
podcasts on YouTube row easy to find
will be live six o'clock six beers a day
yes 6 p.m. est today and then next week
we're starting back on Saturdays at 6
p.m. est so you wanna let us eat so we
can get some numbers finally
[Laughter]
football season about to start
appreciating on even though I obviously
hate destiny why do you feel about
destiny house every also very impressed
you played the actual PC Devils that was
cool well yeah he got shot with the
Golden Gun you think felt right since
you know the crucible and I'm like man I
just got one shot at Batman I'm out
written up at least you try that's all I
said put your money where your mouth it
is hard to get past like you know cheap
supers cuz I do they are they're very
cheap supers but it's like I try to tell
them tell BG that if you want a
competitive fillings trials of Osiris
there's no second to it there's just not
mm-hmm definitely I'll try I'm gonna be
honest if you're a hardcore competitive
pvp guy trials is what you need to play
because chances are when you play trials
you like the supers become a nuisance
that become an advantage in a
disadvantage it's like you know if you
pop you're super too early you're gonna
lose you got the lockout for theirs
because chances are you're only gonna
get one on each side
most the time for every character yeah
somehow we had to we have to bribe or I
mean there's no bribe into it they got a
patreon you can make things cooking
what's going on and wait could if I can
find you can find me on Twitter YouTube
room to kill on Xbox and PlayStation
steam is gaming addict I would be rude I
would be gaming addict on xbox but some
dude made an account in like 2006 and I
can't have it and he has 200 gamers for
okay so I'm not even gonna talk about
that because I'm gonna be flipping out
definitely you know you know
the inner circle Network has definitely
launched a patreon so definitely go
check that out it should be in the
comment section I'm pretty sure a lot of
nice uh you know a lot of nice tears
that you can make yes he's gonna talk to
locale about that uh that I'll order a
tear in the iron load cast I will be
streaming destiny they one nice
streaming it probably for that whole
night yes I I strategically made myself
have the day off
though that's what's up
Lord King where can you find people find
you Twitter and Facebook all other good
stuff I like to give a shout out to Lord
eg for coming through it's always great
to see a young entrepreneur from New
York City doing this thing success in a
way that is different you understand
like the way you did it is you looked at
the the parameters and you changed it
you went outside the box to create your
lane and your lane is fantastic that's
that's a good lane that you you got him
and also the visualization of the you
know the podcast as far as doing the
visual every month or so so that's
that's fantastic I just like to give a
shout out to that um you know one of the
guys that when I did start looking at
podcasts or listening to podcasts weapon
will was one of the ones that I did
listen to and is entertaining on many
different reasons and the fact that you
know you from BK your um the merch hey
guys the merch is in the final phase I
have you know testers out head you know
checking the quality of it stuff looks
great I'm not gonna sell you anything or
have anything sold to you that I
wouldn't personally wear myself or have
my family wearing Oh trouble Lord King
doesn't do anything he wouldn't do try
one
I'm one I want the you know the team to
get fitted in it check it out and I
really need everybody's opinion on these
things because I want you to have the
highest quality you know there's
different tiers to it there's gonna be a
premium tear and it's gonna be you know
the regular tear but I don't want that
regular tear to be better than the tear
that you get anywhere else
noisy Road can find people find you only
what oh gee want to say it was great to
be back at the round table of the
brothers it's been a while in the wild
is gonna go back but I do want to thank
you for coming out to and I don't think
that you hate destiny brother it's just
a different viewpoint which is something
you know I lords podcast was always
stressed on the beginning you know
different viewpoints different walks of
life
oh yeah you got some of us that can't
stand the division some of us they like
you sorry for cutting you off is I
actually went out and purchased the halo
wars to complete you know I put I saw
what you like and I said let me try it
let me let me get that same feeling this
is why we have the division try again
sir he actually played their best debate
I watch the stream I was like all right
at least he gave it a shot
I usually catch me on xbox live at Lord
zero ILP you can catch the playback
gaming crew we changed our air data is
now gonna be on Thursday night set I
want to say 9:30 central time we are
flying the tee I see colors now nice
okay fan there it's all great yes sir
so make sure to turn in you know after
our spark ideas our new name and you
know it's your adult centered gaming
show you know cussing you know all kinds
of stuff entertainment days pay
we put a crew you know I respect that
that after I was in of course like I
said like a kid over here we spreading
that realness from the ILP that's
telling me what you want to hear but you
needed real quick that we're gonna pay
the bills right quick um yo first of all
football season yo starts next week the
IOP time will change we will be at 11
a.m. Eastern so put that in your clocks
new cameras I'll send the tweets out no
longer at 1 p.m. because we are not
competing with the lords and that fat we
do not do that
so 11 a.m. will be the new start time
make sure you guys get that straight
also a lot of people I'm still getting
you guys hit me up on all my LP channel
that channel will not go away however
please like and subscribe to the inner
circle Network that's where we are
that's where the last changes are sewing
guys commenting on old videos late you
gotta get over here to the inner circle
that's the movement now so get over and
also for the audio we're up on par being
all that good stuff YouTube iTunes
SoundCloud all the support really helps
us shout everybody in the chat today
chat was lit as usual and we're in this
thing and thanks for coming to sleep is
for the weak